The Query Envelope standard
serves to provide identification
that is unique within the network.
This includes the requester ID,
their name, e-mail and organization.
It also provides the purpose,
priority and type of the query
using seven purpose codes.
For example, treat for treatment.
Its priority from one to five,
with one being the highest.
And an alphanumeric type that
can be as many as 20 characters.
It identifies the level
of PHI that's involved.
Is this aggregated patient data?
Limited data,
de-identified patient data, or
fully identified protected
health information?
And finally the timing,
what's the submission date and time, and
optionally, when should
the query be executed.